MARY POPPINS is back in Cherry Tree Lane
so get ready to trip a little light
fantastic with everyone's favorite
British nanny yippie Kay we be lovers
I'm Jan and today I'm revealing the most
supercalifragilistic expialidocious
Easter eggs nostalgic callbacks cameos
and secrets hidden in Mary Poppins
returns if you spotted any others do
share them in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to get all my new Mary
Poppins videos some mild spoilers ahead
if you haven't seen the movie yet though
I avoid any major plot reveals during
lin-manuel Miranda's opening number we
get a mini tour of London with one
iconic location Saint Paul's Cathedral
making a lovely return from the original
movie as the camera passes over the
Cathedral look carefully and you'll spot
an old lady on the steps and as the
camera moves up a flock of pigeons
scatter and fly away this initial moment
is a very sweet Amash to the bird woman
from the 1964 film who sold breadcrumbs
on the steps of st. Paul's for tuppence
a bag
there's a lovely sequence in the new
movie where the children disappear down
the bathtub drain with Mary as she sings
can you imagine that this glorious
fantasy sequence is a deep Curt Easter
Egg to an under the water scene based on
the books that didn't make it into the
first Mary Poppins film and it also has
shades of the underwater sequence from
Disney's 1971 movie Bedknobs and
Broomsticks and that connection is no
coincidence because the song the
beautiful briny witch Angela landsbury
and David Tomlinson saying during their
watery adventures in Bedknobs and
Broomsticks was actually originally
written for 1964 s Mary Poppins and
there's even more connections between
the movies because Angela Lansbury plays
the part of the balloon lady in the Mary
Poppins sequel and her fellow Bedknobs
and Broomsticks star David Tomlinson was
the original mr. banks the can you
imagine that underwater scene and song
also tipped their hat to Disney's Peter
Pan film with a pirate ship appearing
together with the line some pirates
follow treasure maps they searched the
world for buried gold they won't grow up
and don't grow old
the animated English countryside
sequence from the original Mary Poppins
is one of the movies most treasured
moments and the sequel doesn't
disappoint when it creates its own
version this time around the family's
rural Dalton Bowl serves as a portal
into
fantasy world with the painting on the
bowl surface giving us a glimpse of
what's inside the world similar to
Bert's pavement paintings in the first
film the decision to employ old-school
hand-drawn animation techniques for
scenes inside the vault was a deliberate
tribute to the original movie by the
sequel's director Rob Marshall and to
make Mary Poppins Jack and the children
look like they really belonged in the 2d
hand-drawn world the costume design team
literally painted on top of the fabric
he used to make their costumes the scale
of production for these sequences was
immense with the entire process taking
16 months to complete and involving more
than 70 animators some of whom even came
out of retirement for the opportunity to
work on a sequel to such a Disney
classic a Royal Doulton Bowl also
features in the second Mary Poppins book
although what happens there is much
darker and scarier as Jane ends up
trapped inside the bowl with a creepy
old man who tells her she's gone back in
time 60 years and he intends to keep her
there
the Royal Doulton Music Hall is also the
setting for an especially inventive
musical number called a cover is not the
book in which Mary and Jack perform a
vaudeville song that's stacked with
Easter eggs 2 P L Travers original Mary
Poppins books for example the lyrics
mentioned Nellie Rubina a human-sized
wooden doll who gives the children
conversation sweets in the book Mary
Poppins comes back
lin-manuel Miranda gets to demonstrate
the kind of verbal dexterity that's
become his signature in musicals like
Hamilton when he performs a 1930s style
rap as part of a cover is not the book
but Miranda's rap esque moment is also a
hat tip to the Ratatat section in jolly
holiday where Bert's speak things about
all the women who can't quite match up
to Mary Poppins iverson Sybil have wages
that are winning and prudence and
Gwendolyn center are spinnin be be
delightful modest disarming Janice
charming on stage in the background
there's also a book titled the day out
which is a title of the second chapter
of P L Travers first Mary Poppins book
and that chapter was the inspiration for
the Johnny holiday scene in the first
movie another book in this scene called
the cat that looked at a king as an
easter egg - a chapter from the book
Mary Poppins opens the door which was
also adapted into a short film starring
Julie Andrews which appeared on the 2004
DVD release of Mary Poppins the lovable
penguins from the original films Anna
Mae
scenes also make an appearance during
the musical section the Penguins which
dance with Burt in the first film this
time around beg to dance with Mary
Poppins herself and later they also
dance with jag Mary even honks the beak
of one of the penguins which feels like
a fun nod to how one of the four
penguins in the original films seemed
especially enamored with Mary anything
for you Mary Poppins you're our favorite
person a new character we meet in the
sequel is Mary's cousin Topsy who runs a
Fixit shop that gets turned upside down
every second Wednesday her scenes with
Mary Jack and the children feel like
Anna Marsh - the first films floating
scene with Uncle Albert and if you keep
your eyes peeled you'll see the
weathervane from the 1964 movie during
the turning turtle song in Topsy's shop
interestingly Meryl Streep's Topsy is a
mix of two characters from the books
Mary's cousin Arthur turvy who Mary also
asked to mend a cracked Royal Doulton
bowl and a woman named Topsy who marries
Arthur turvy and similar to the film
everything in Arthur Toby's life is the
opposite of what it should be one day a
month Dick Van Dyke makes a very special
cameo in Mary Poppins as mr. Dawes jr.
which is a little inside joke for fans
of the original film because in that
movie he played mr. door senior the
father of the character he plays in the
sequel and the amazing little dance the
93 year old actor performs in the new
movie is also reminiscent to some of
Bert's famous dance moves from the first
film such as his dance alongside the
animated Penguins and his chimney sweep
routine on the rooftops of London
there's also a wink and a nod to his
double role in the first movie when the
sequel replays how he was credited for
his second part as mr. Dores senior so
once again during the credits when we
see dick Van Dyke's name the letters
first appear scrambled before they
magically rearrange themselves to reveal
his real name and when Dick Van Dyke
sits down to tell the story about
Michael's tuppence he smiley starts by
saying once upon a time there was a man
with a wooden leg which is a clever
little call back to the first films
running joke about a wooden leg named
Smith in the 1964 movie dick Van Dyke's
Bert first told the joke to Uncle Albert
then the banks children passed it on to
their father who eventually told it to
dick Van Dyke's mr. Dawes senior who
later
laughing from the joke as well as Dick
Van Dyke returning from the first film
there's also a fun cameo by Karen
dotrice who played the original Jane
Banks in Mary Poppins returns doe tree
stands upon the street outside the banks
house asking for directions to 19 Cherry
Tree Lane which is funny because that
would have been her neighbor's house
when she leaves doe trees politely says
many thanks sincerely which is exactly
how Jane and Michael signed off their
advert for a new nanny in the first film
actor David Tomlinson who played Jane's
father is no longer with us but this
shot of a man in the park looks a lot
like George banks and the way the kite
knocks his hat off feels like a literal
hat tip to the original movie where mr.
banks had his bowler hat punched through
when he was sacked also look out for
photographs of the original mr. and mrs.
banks in the living room at 17 Cherry
Tree Lane and there are plenty more
delicious callbacks to the original film
one of my favorites is where Mary
arrives at the banks home and addresses
the gobsmacked Michael Mary pence
sleeves your mouth please Michael we are
still not a codfish Jean banks still
rather inclined to giggle Lacey
close your mouth please Michael we are
not a codfish now you Jane rather
inclined giggle doesn't put things away
there Mary admires herself in the mirror
and walks away although her reflection
stays behind watching and raising an
eyebrow if she leaves in a sweet
throwback to where Mary's reflection
took on a life of its own in the first
film joining her in singing a spoonful
of sugar before watching Mary leave and
then winking and then there's some
classic moments from the first film
replayed with a twist such as Mary
Poppins sliding up the banisters if she
did in the 1964 film only this time Jane
and Michael don't see her also Mary
Poppins and the children tidy away the
mess made by Michael and Jane with some
magical assistance just as Mary did with
the young Michael and Jane in the first
movie you might remember miss Locke's
dog Andrew from the original movie as
Mary Poppins returns a set around 25
years after the first film miss lock now
has a new dog called Willoughby which is
a fun little Easter egg because in the
books miss Locke has two dogs called
Andrew and Willa beam and while Mary
returning on a kite at the start of the
film has taken from P L Travers second
book
MARY POPPINS comes back the fact she say
she'll stay with the banks family until
the door opens comes from the third book
MARY POPPINS opens the door the kite
also still has the suffragettes votes
for women's sash that mrs. banks
attached to it in the first movie there
are other intriguing Easter eggs too
such as the Robin or Mary Poppins hat
her talking parrot umbrella and the st.
Paul snow globe and I talked about why
they're so important in another video
add a card with the link here as soon as
I upload it so subscribe and hit the
bell to get notified as soon as it's
posted tap left to find out all the big
differences between the sequel and the
original or tap write for my full Mary
Poppins playlist thanks for watching and
see you next time
yippie Kay movie lovers